no es la primera vez que la Península de
crimea es atacada pero el ataque de esta
madrugada llega en un momento
estratégico para Ucrania días antes de
que se planee el comienzo de esa
contraofensiva que tiene como objetivo
recuperar territorios ocupados por Rusia
especialmente esta península que fue
anexada ilegalmente por el gobierno de
Moscú en el 2014 este ataque según se
conoce fue con al menos dos drones que
atacaron estos depósitos de gasolina y
allí en ese puerto de sebastopol donde
están los navíos que hacen parte de la
flota rusa que navegan en el mar Negro y
que son fundamentales para esta
contraofensiva no solamente para la
defensa de crimea sino algunas de esas
regiones del sur de Ucrania que siguen
ocupadas por las fuerzas de Moscú Y eso
también llega a 24 horas después de ese
ataque masivo con misiles a Ucrania y
donde hubo la mayor número de de las
últimas semanas Esto fue en esta pequeña
población de humana en el centro del
país donde uno de los misiles impactó un
edificio de nueve pisos allí fallecieron
más de 25 personas entre ellos varios
niños lo que causó una gran indignación
en el país pero también como se decía
hoy en este país en Ucrania estos
ataques tanto el de esta madrugada en
crimea como el de ayer en todo el país
todo Ucrania hacen parte de estas
preparativos tanto de Rusia como del
gobierno de kiev para esta
contraofensiva que como decía ayer el
ministro de defensa de Ucrania estaría
próxima a comenzar en los próximos días
cuando mejore el tiempo y cuando los
comandantes lo decidan